michelle obama is still speaking out on
the issues that she championed as first
lady
she is now the star and the executive
producer of the netflix show
waffles and mochi this children's
program is terrific it focuses on
teaching kids
the value of healthy eating by sharing
stories and traditions from around the
world
but monday only on cbs this morning
she's going to reveal waffles and
mochi's
next adventure these two are very very
busy we sat down with her in washington
where she told us
why she's very excited about her
upcoming initiative with partnership for
a healthier america
we also spoke with mrs obama about some
of the other challenges facing america
we asked about her reaction to the
jury's decision to find derek chovin
guilty
for the death of george floyd after the
verdict she and former president
obama released a statement saying the
jury in minneapolis
did the right thing she told us what
compelled them to speak out after that
critical decision
the goal is to let leaders lead but in
in certain times people
you know look to us often well what do
you think how do you feel
um and we know that while we're all
breathing a sigh of relief over the
verdict there's still
work to be done um and so we we can't
sort of say great that happen
let's move on i know that people in the
black community don't feel that way
because they many of us still live in
fear as we go to the grocery store
or worry about our dogs walking our dogs
or
allowing our children to get a license i
mean just imagine
aren't your girls driving they're
driving but every time they get in a car
by themselves i worry about what
assumption is being made by somebody who
doesn't know everything about them
the fact that they are good students and
polite girls but
maybe they're playing their music a
little loud maybe somebody sees the back
of their head
and makes an assumption i like so many
parents black kids have to that the the
the
innocent act of getting a license puts
fear in our hearts um so
i think i think we have to talk about it
more and we have to ask our
fellow citizens to listen a bit more and
to believe us
and to know we don't want to be out
there marching i mean all those black
lives matters kids they'd rather not
have to worry about this
they're taken to the streets because
they have to
they're trying to have people understand
that that we're real folks
and the fear that many have of so many
of us is
irrational and it's based on a history
that is just
it's sad and it's dark and it's time for
us to move beyond that
yeah on monday you can see more of our
exclusive conversation with the former
first lady
about her ongoing mission to ensure that
all families have access to healthy
foods
it is the focus of her upcoming project
with waffles and mochi it's called past
love like that title we also spoke with
mrs obama about the impact this pandemic
is having
on our collective mental health she's
talked candidly about her concerns
and concerns that she has for her own
family during these racially and
politically divided times
you know it's very rare for the two of
them to issue a statement about anything
they try very much not to get involved
um
in a political way to speak certainly
against any party they're very very
careful about that but i think they both
felt
considering the times that we're living
in that they had to say something i
thought what she said was very
interesting
when she said you know like they don't
want to be out there marching they gotta
think right about you yeah you know
she's right about that it's it's like
they're watching because
because they're because they're fearful
yeah and you got to question your
assumptions i mean if you're working in
law enforcement if you're that person
behind somebody in a vehicle you've got
to ask yourself is my first
uh idea here my best idea about what's
going on yeah
and the assumptions that are made when
she says when they don't know people you
know
i was talking about my son walking the
dog his dog and sometimes he thinks i
better put on my
t-shirt i mean just the fact that you
even think that way that you feel
in danger at any time it is it's very
it's very jarring yeah